est ce qu'on risque ordinn trop d'hommes
au québec en leur honneur c'est bien
mais est-ce qu on le fait trop ou est-ce
que ok j'avoue que des hommes et parfois
pour propos de bonnes raisons vous
trouvez maintenant qu'ils ont et qui
mériterait d'être garde viau qui créent
des biscuits alors que les femmes au
québec seulement quatre circonscriptions
sur les 125 porte le nom d'une femme
jeanne mance marguerite bourgeoys la
peltrie et verchères
on apprenait récemment que seul compte
et celui de crémazie allait changer de
nom en hommage aux hockeyeurs
légendaires vont rester chez moi qui
aime le rock échoue c'est vraiment
sympathique mais mon reflex à mathay ça
a été quand est-ce qu'on voit un nom de
femme elle avait bien raison
elle a bien raison van orman c'est parce
que les femmes représentent plus de 52%
de la population du québec tournoi
marie-gérin-lajoie on a eu de l'effet de
thérèse casgrain il a fallu batailler
ferme et on doit la première députée
ministre fera qu'un clown carlingue est
décédé récemment
mais pas question de faire quoi que ce
soit au tour au droit du d'époux du
mairie mais seulement d'améliorer le
statut de sa conjointe
est ce que ces femmes là pour avoir leur
nom dans une transcription parce que non
seulement il pourrait elle devrait avoir
ce sont des femmes se sont battues
pendant dix ans maintenant 30 ans 40 ans
à l'occasion pour que les femmes du
québec comme les femmes ailleurs dans le
monde obtiennent le droit non seulement
de voter et d'être élues et de servir
leurs concitoyens
on peut penser aussi à des femmes qui
ont livré des choses extraordinaires au
québec en termes de développement social
et économique pire me levasseur la
fondatrice de 5 justin de l'enfant jésus
et grande femme de l'action sociale et
populaire
je pense à tes à robin qu'une lui de
montréal qui s'intitule les employés du
textile dans notre tout plein mais
encore faut-il qu'on ait une volonté de
le faire
comment fonctionne la dénomination la
commission de la représentation
électorale du québec justifie celle de
crémazie de la façon suivante la
désignation toponymique commémorative
d'un lieu doit présenter une relation
significative avec celui ci dans ce
cas-ci maurice richard a habité ce
territoire
une cinquantaine d'années et quelques
ailes et les pressions qui pourraient
être exercées justement pour qu'on ait
davantage de femmes on pourrait prendre
des modèles étrangers il ya un très beau
modèle qui le modèle de l'espagne
actuellement les que quand vous ouvrez
une nouvelle rue 80% des noms de rues
doivent être des noms de femmes parce
qu'il ya un rattrapage énorme à faire de
ce côté là
[Musique]